the EU is keen to sign trade deals with
global partners like Canada Japan the US
and others in the Mediterranean Asia and
Latin America lately there's been a lot
of talk about transparency and criticism
on how trade deals are made so the first
question is why does Europe do these
trade deals we are natural news
Development Company work on contracts
developing industrial medical cameras
for specific customer applications we do
a lot of business with the United States
and we do almost exclusively exports and
we expect from free trade agreements in
general that it lowers barriers and
helps small companies to address new
markets from the consumer perspective
trade deals can be good because they
will put pressure on markets because
there will be more competition on
domestic markets that means normally in
theory at least lower prices better
products higher quality and innovation
so this is good for consumers
negotiating trade agreements is complex
and involves different players the
European Parliament the governments
through the council the European
Commission civil society and businesses
big and small the European Commission
receives a mandate from the EU Member
States to negotiate on their behalf
so does everything happen behind closed
doors when we negotiate every time for a
negotiation around after negotiation
around we report to the council or their
representatives and to the European
Parliament and we also engage regularly
with the civil society so it's open and
we try to make a negotiations as
transparent and engaging as possible and
we believe that it should become a
principle that you should not always
have to currently and put lightly
request access to the mandate and access
to the to the position paper so this is
a first step make transparency and
default ruled we have
basically all the European texts online
the negotiating positions the background
papers a lot of reports and references
are online for everybody to see and this
is very deliberate because I think
transparency is key in order to get
acceptance and confidence on these
negotiations the process of trade
negotiation has really changed so the
parliament is deeply involved and the
council has also to be involved and
there is a democratic control of the
process and that's important there
should also be a possibility to really
provide constructive input to the
Commission and that's still missing for
the moment I would say as in every
complex negotiation with a lot of
stakeholders there are different
viewpoints so how can you involve as
many voices as possible many
stakeholders for instance
representatives of the trade unions the
business small and big like
environmental organization consumers
organizations they are very important
because they have specific knowledge and
they highlight concerns sometimes I have
you thought about this or that and that
is very important because it feeds into
the process when we elaborate are
negotiating positions and then we can
report back to them
Japan skillet is important lop twist the
found receiver is Salish national system
de caña de Secoya avec - little trapeze
la planète commences on days ago with a
cappella - waka suave Cluj upon cosa
suave o'clock away do suitcases were
avec le canada elicit a sneaky concern
la vie quotidian the situation over PA
we have access to the protocol of the
negotiation so we are really aware about
the things which are going on and we are
really serious inside the European
Parliament and not try to eject
bad agreement so it's important that
everyone knows what is happening and
that the council and Parliament are well
informed
but where does this process lead a good
unfair deal that is good for the
consumers for the for the workers for
the business in Europe is what we are
aiming at but I think there will be very
few surprises in the antics that would
be a draft to say yes or no that will
have to be adopted by Member States and
the European Parliament so after the
commission gets a mandate from the --use
Member States it works with the European
Parliament it listens to businesses big
and especially small and it engages with
civil society it pays attention to all
voices it has to if trade deals are to
work because in the end trade is all
about jobs and growth the EU member
states and the European Parliament are
involved throughout the negotiations and
it is they who have the final say to
approve or reject the deal